the military is deeply ingrained in this
city's DNA from the modern naval base of
Devon ports all the way back to perhaps
this nation's greatest naval pioneer one
wonders what he'd make of the way our
Navy looks now fallen half centuries on
from Sir Francis Drake's
circumnavigation of the globe and it's
pretty clear that Britannia no longer
rules the waves nor the skies no they
are for that matter but our own forces
remain one of the most important ways in
which we as a nation project our power
that's why it's essential to regularly
question what our military can and
cannot do and the way in which we treat
those who fight our wars when they come
home having been in power for the best
part of a decade having presided over
the modern leaders most significant cuts
to our armed forces the Conservatives
must answer for their records
Brian's served two years in the army but
then found himself in a home from
homeless veterans run by the charity a
LaBrie I was really depressed really
I've gotten to arrow in that last one
last one I got into that era when they
started trying to run away I suppose I
don't know what's going on really is
tonight and all my friends that were all
like that so I just jumped on the
bandwagon really from then on I just you
know in that present on me life is any
when I lost me son not a really sort of
my life fight you know with the help of
John nfk and McKee work or ally or abhar
I mean my friends in the ice sort of me
not fight well David served almost two
decades in the Navy including a tour in
Afghanistan until he was medically
retired it was really hard leaving one
military family and joining the civilian
side of it it's it's that transition and
I was I didn't know do some physical
injuries what I'd be able to do outside
and luckily and that's where active Plus
came along in Whitehall the vultures are
circling emboldened by a p.m. with
precious little room for manoeuvre the
defence secretary now openly calls for
more money
even if
that in itself won't be enough the local
MP has been one of the armed forces most
vocal supporters of late with a wonder
given that he himself served three tours
of duty and Afghanistan I do think you
know there's been a significant problem
since 2000 that in the early 2000 when
we did Iraq and we clearly committed to
things we could not do we did the same
in Afghanistan
some of us learnt the very painful
lessons of that and so people like me
I'm afraid when you get into positions
like I am now determined to sort of
learn those lessons if the cuts continue
in the way in which they have since the
Conservatives came into power in the
coalition if there isn't that change in
strategic direction and that you are
calling for long term will we be able to
project power in the way we once were
well no we won't and I don't think the
British people will take that but the
great thing about politics is that
actually we're not in charge the brief
we don't get the basics right in this
administration at the moment of which
I'm afraid defense is one of them then
we will pay a price at the ballot box
but is there truly the political will to
improve things to roll back on almost a
decade of downsizing absent such a
desire will people like Bryan and
David's continue to put the needs of the
country above their own
near paterson Sky News